et rarement rares sont ceux qui viennent
nous voir pour se faire alors on a très
très peu de demandes de conseils à
l'origine il faut savoir que beaucoup
d'entreprises seul pénalisent pas par
leur métier mais c'est pas se pénalise
par l'absence de compétences en matière
de gestion et que donc nous ce qu'on
leur donne comme conseil c'est des
conseils relatifs à notre
comment on recouvrement mais d'entrée de
jeu on leur dit de bien faire les choses
de bien de bien déclarer etc etc des
conseils aussi pour ne pas faire de
travail clandestin parce que ça c'est
c'est rédhibitoire un travail de
l'entreprise qui fait du travail
clandestin à terme il est appelé à
disparaître enfin voilà tout un tas
d'éléments de conseils qui font que
d'entrée de jeu on a un rapport positif
avec une entreprise pour nous
l'entreprise et importante si
l'entreprise ne vit pas forcément on n'a
pas de cotisation donc on a tout intérêt
à ce que les entreprises existent et il
faut pour qu'elles existent il faut que
d'entrer de jeu elle soit bien
accompagnées